this video is brought to you by
Squarespace
ants
this video is about ants why because
scientists recently figured out that
there are 20 quadrillion ants in the
entire world and this is an insane
number that is like 20 million billion
oh man I'd love to see how big that
ampile is oh hey look scientists have
calculated how many ants are on earth
the number is so big it's unimaginable
ah
we simply cannot imagine 20 quadrillion
ants in one pile it just doesn't work
I'll do it myself
[Music]
all right so we've all had experiences
with ants before perhaps you left a
cookie out on the counter overnight and
the next morning you found ants
everywhere that's how you get ants or
maybe you're out on a hike and
accidentally stepped on an ant hill
causing ants to flood out of the ground
like a zombie horde no matter where you
go you can find ants unless you're in
Antarctica well this sucks Antarctica in
fact there are over 15
000 different named species of ants in
the world they range all the way from
like one millimeter in length like the
karabara atoma here
tiny all the way up to 30 or 40
millimeters in length like the bullet
ant oh God why did I put this on my
finger that's terrifying It Might Sting
me
oh it's hot but if we want accurate
results we can't just use any ants we
need to find the most average ants using
data from the original research paper I
determined that the average weight of a
live ant is 4.13 milligrams but anyway
we still don't know how big that is do
you include the antennas and legs chop
off the legs do you assume they're
squished up I chose to split the
difference and assume that there's going
to be some overlap but not like a full
squish that means that our average ant
in this video measures in at about 4.5
millimeters in length now we can get
into this video
but first a word from our sponsor
Squarespace are you looking to start an
online business or something like that
well you're going to need a beautiful
website and Squarespace has your back
because they're an all-in-one platform
they have everything you need to get
your business really going for instance
let's say you're teaching classes and
your clients need to book appointments
with you well they can easily see your
schedule make their own appointments
adjust them if necessary all links to
the API inside of Squarespace it's
really nice because it takes the hassle
out of coordinating schedules I mean I
hate doing that and if their schedules
don't work well you can provide videos
thanks to the video studio app that
Squarespace provides you can actually
make your own videos or your clients
that can't make it and even though your
website is your Hub of content you can
actually integrate all of this stuff
with your social media accounts and push
all of your website content to your
socials really effortlessly all links to
Squarespace head on over to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com Corridor crew and you'll
be able to get 10 off your first domain
kind of like these ants are going to
want to get their own domain oh my God
gross squarespace.com quarter crew check
it out
[Music]
so 20 quadrillion ants is a lot of ants
but Earth also has a lot of land 134
million square kilometers to be exact if
we don't include Antarctica because duh
that averages out to 150 ants for every
square meter of land 148 149 150. I mean
take a look around you how much ground
can you see just imagine that for every
square meter of land there's 150 ants
walking around and this is them trying
to like space themselves out evenly
across the whole planet but of course
ant distribution is not perfectly even
with the highest numbers located in
rainforests a study in West Africa
determined that there are roughly 2 000
ants for every square meter of land
there which is enough to make me feel
very uncomfortable now like one ant not
a problem but a swarm of thousands whole
different story
because that is only the beginning there
are 8 billion people on Earth which
means that for every one of us there are
two and a half million
of them
[Music]
okay okay that's enough
yeah pack tightly together two and a
half million ants would form a circle
six meters across that's 20 feet and
that just barely fits inside of our
studio here what is a center for ants
what's crazy is that at this scale you
can't even see individual ants anymore
in fact there are more ants in this shot
than there are pixels in HD video that's
why this video is in 4k
oh no but of course ants are famous for
self-assembling into complex structures
like Bridges though I hope you never
have The Misfortune of walking through
one of these oh ants get a bad
reputation for being pests but they're
incredibly important to our ecosystem
they aerate the soil speed up
decomposition and they improve plant
growth across the globe despite being
creepy crawlers we need them except for
fire ants though no they can go die in a
fire
so two and a half million ants for every
person on Earth
that makes me wonder what a real Ant-Man
would look like
all of these ants clumped together in
human form would be as tall
as Danny DeVito are you looking at me
I'm Danny DeVito what were you expecting
a giant they're a pile of ants ants they
just look bigger when they're flat they
would however be lighter than Danny
DeVito coming in at just 10 kilograms
Which is less than a one wheel a lot
less so not that tall not that heavy
kind of makes them seem a little less
scary right like come on I could totally
take this thing on in a fight I
get back here and there are eight
billion of these things running around
on the planet one for every single
person
if all 20 quadrillion ants could cling
together into one giant Giga ball how
big with this pile of ants be
it would have a diameter of 860 meters
making it taller than the tallest
building in the entire world which is
the Burj Khalifa in Dubai not even Tom
Cruise would be sitting as high as that
ball
it would also look pretty bizarre
appearing almost like Smooth metal you
can see the bumpiness of ants when close
up but like at this distance their
texture is just too small to see making
the ball appear smooth and this massive
ants would completely dwarf any City you
put it next to obviously this is a bit
unrealistic because I have the gravity
turned off I mean this many ants would
crush themselves under their own weights
but here's the thing about balls of ants
they behave like liquid meaning that
when I turn the gravity back on
Splash
even with the viscosity a million times
higher than water they would still ooze
through the city until every single
street is submerged in a sludge of ants
a little bit
eventually though this ant ooze will
spread itself out flat how much area
would this flat ant blanket cover it's a
lot let me go get Sam and Nico samaniko
what state are you guys from Minnesota
well did you know that if all 20
quadrillion ants could be laid out flat
it would cover your entire home state oh
no antasota would be the 12th largest
state in the entire country and
Minneapolis would be terrifying place to
live
a minnesota-sized patch of ant skin that
could just crawl around Yeah Carl I
didn't even think about the crawling
part of it it could just migrate around
the planet oh God
snico so we've seen the scale of ants in
three dimensions and now we've seen them
in two but what would one dimension look
like one of the behaviors ants are best
known for is Marching In lines they use
their antennae to detect the pheromones
of other ants to find Pathways from
potential food back to the colonies they
came from a spider always seems like
they're marching along invisible
highways
who let the cookie out so if all of the
ants in the entire world were to line up
butt to mouth how long would that line
be take a guess how many times around
the earth do you think this line would
go an average ant is .0045 meters times
20 quadrillion
90 billion kilometers
planets
[Music]
ran that is such an astronomical
distance that I think we need a better
unit of measurement for this the
astronomical unit the distance from
Earth to the Sun that means that our
line of ants which stretch from here to
the Sun and back
300 times
think of it this way that's the setting
sun behind me here in La meaning that
the Earth orbiting around the Sun is
going that way having just come from
that way so if we could shoot a chain of
ants into space to trail behind the
Earth first off we'd be shooting them at
like a hundred thousand kilometers an
hour 80 times the speed of a bullet but
we would be shooting them continuously
non-stop for 95 years before we finally
run out of ants
good riddance
good
and
20 quadrillion is such a large number
that our brains just can't really
conceive it and so what I try to do with
this whole scale series is to take the
unimaginable and imagine it which means
that there's just one last thing to do
hi how's it going good how are you my
name is Sabine Newton I'm Patrick
schulteist yeah that's right the lead
authors of the paper and the quote that
started this whole thing have actually
been helping me with this video they
provided me with information to figure
out the average size of the ants and I
just thought it was fitting that after
all of that I could show them the actual
visuals I came up with to find out if it
really is unimaginable there's more
absolute stars in the galaxy but that
doesn't help you visualize it in any way
it's just another way of putting numbers
as far as visualizations go no one has
done anything but really helps you
really I do have some to show you all
right ready wow
it's scary yes
is coming look it's uh it's a weapon of
mass destruction I guess we don't I
gotta ask is it imaginable now it is
imaginable now definitely indeed it is
totally impossible yes you've done the
impossible we can now imagine what these
ants look like well fantastic thank you
guys so much for your help it's been an
honor honestly so I want to do more of
these types of videos and I think you've
inspired me to continue doing that so
thank you dude we're glad to find you
thanks for investing a month of your
life just send us a link as soon as it's
online yeah we'll do have a great day
bye bye all right bye they're so cool
man this is a fun video to do thank you
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this one subscribe for more videos like
this I'm going to be doing more of these
this year and uh
ants